I don't want to live 250 more years
because they called me a thief. You
can tell a soldier that he is a
murderer but not that he is a thief, but whether
you stole or not, I
came here because they said they were going
to distribute money, that's what I told you to
convince you idiot And then
good afternoon
accounting errors
[Music]
dad This is the accountant who is going to
help us completely trustworthy
military family I was studying your
court case she says that you ordered the
murder and disappearance of thousands of
Chileans there is also bad money  There have been
My children don't know how to work and I don't
want them to starve of course
[Music]
a young French accountant there are
creatures of the devil who have no soul
and I'm going to save them
you liked to steal no
and your brothers were imprisoned  in
political embezzlement all the
generals who win wars have
rights of course
the Chilean army taught me as a
value the act of
someone got into his suitcase he brought
stakes in silver hammers
we
[Music]
you I'm going to kill four vampires